[Music]
[Applause]
hello i'm heather andersshot director of
graduate studies for comparative media
studies
um
today our speaker for our colloquium
series is jens pohlmann who is a
research associate at the center for
media communication and information
research
at the university of bremen he received
his phd from stanford university in 2017
and his research centers on internet
policy discourse in both germany and the
united states and his first book the
creation of an avant-garde brand heiner
mueller's self-presentation in the
german public sphere will be published
this fall congratulations that's great
um
the title of his talk today is platform
regulation and the digital public sphere
comparing the discourse in germany and
the united states take it away jens
all right thank you very much for the
kind introduction i'm very excited uh
about having the opportunity to present
my work here today
uh so to uh to let you know i am a
visiting scholar here at mit actually
since uh since october i think so i've
been here for six months uh or so
and i enjoyed it very much um kurt fent
is hosting me and i had the pleasure of
you know taking some classes with him so
i met with
with undergrads from mit
also together with him and two europes
were working on this research project
that i that i will uh present here today
so i'm very thankful for that um as well
and i can say that i've been working
with the with the libraries very much so
aj tornado uh has been helping me and us
so the team to to deal with uh access to
data resources and all this has been uh
tremendously helpful and
exciting for me so a big thanks to to
mit and to all of you
and uh the only thing that didn't work
out so well uh actually because of the
pandemic was meeting people and reaching
out to to you you guys when i came it
was still kind of you know difficult and
now i see it's getting better but now
i'm leaving already next week so that's
the only thing that that didn't work out
i guess as planned but today maybe a
chance to you know present some of my
work and get into discussions with you
and potentially we can continue some of
that
in in the future
so let me see let me um share my
my screen
so that
yeah so i guess now you should be able
to see my slides so that's the the title
for today
um
i will to jump ahead and give you the
glitter that's germans that should be
the structure right it's the road map
first thing is a is a short introduction
about you know this topic of the talk
today but also generally my research
then i will talk a bit uh more in depth
about the
network enforcement act so short
version is an sdg so a particular
anti-hate speech law in germany that i
think is very interesting
also for you know an international
perspective and a transatlantic
perspective on platform regulation
then in point three i will give you some
insights on the research that i have
been doing in the last kind of two three
years on this net sdg working with text
corpora analyzing this discourse i want
to want to show you what we have done
and zoom particularly in uh for this
overblocking analysis what is
overblocking and why have people you
know talking about this with regards uh
to net cg so so intensively that is if
you will that's the the main part of or
the main argument the main questions
that i want to uh put out here uh in
this conversation and then the last
point is research that i have done or
that we are doing here at mit
uh so i want to you know talk about the
uh the u.s side of things so that
section 230 of the communications
decency act i guess that will be brief
but i by but i want to say
what we have done here and also talk
about access to data resources for text
data mining because that's what we have
been
uh been involved with
particularly in the last couple of weeks
so that's the roadmap
uh let's jump right into uh so platform
regulation in germany and united states
is the is the
uh
is the main topic why is it important i
think the big question is so who can and
actually who should determine the
structure of the evolving digital public
sphere that is the big uh question and
it uh is particularly really relevant
when it comes to this net sdg law i will
explain it later but as i see it uh or i
guess you can at least
take it this way that netsdg and the
content moderation practices of
platforms
with their community standards or as
community guidelines as they sometimes
say these are competing regulatory
systems that shape what we can say on
these platforms and by doing that they
also shape what can be said in the
digital public sphere and what the
digital public sphere actually consists
of
and obviously that is very important and
it is so important because the the
public sphere and the digital public
sphere lays the foundations of you know
forming political opinions both you know
and everyday interactions as well as uh
on election day and it's so crucial
obviously for
democracy and western liberal
democracies in particular
um and what you can see here is this
cartoon that i sometimes like to show so
you have an sdg on the left side and big
platforms on the on the right and the
middle is it's us potentially right the
users and we are you know poked at i
guess at least here uh and it seems that
sometimes we get into to the middle uh
we're sandwiched in this kind of fight
for um yeah for for power over speech
um and i i think that in my my research
one of the cane one of the key issues is
trying to find ways in which we can
empower us ourselves i guess you know
the users in which they can have as much
influence as as possible and can make
the shape of this digital public sphere
as whatever democratic um as possible so
that's why what i think you know is
important about about my own research
um so let's talk about
about this network enforcement act so
netsdg
i you know i have a couple of slides
with text i'm sorry about that but i'm
gonna you know give you so i'll you know
i'll talk and then you can additionally
read if you want to um the point is this
net cg was enacted in july of 2017 and
then it came into effect uh in january
2018 so a little transitional phase
and there was a there was a very
controversial discussion about this law
both in the bundesliga which is the
german parliament as well as in the
media in germany uh but also in the
united states um at least you know among
among scholars
and internationally
to give you a bit of a historical
context i think it's important to be
aware of what happened before this law
was enacted obviously we have the brexit
referendum 2016 as well as the
u.s presidential election in 2016.
cambridge analytica analytica became
known and people were aware of the fact
that
at least potentially
democratic decision making could be
influenced by
uh the yeah
uh
what by the
using let's say of of uh online
platforms and basically manipulating
potentially what what voters may want to
do or want to say so at least that was
that was there people were thinking
about this at the time so it was seen as
a danger that this political
decision-making process could be
hijacked by using uh social media
platforms
there are two other particularly german
things that were important on the one
hand there was a big election coming up
in 2017 and people were afraid that
similar things as happened in 2016 could
happen in germany as well
um and there was this shift to the right
in germany after the european refugee
crisis you may remember
angela merkel opened the borders people
were welcome from syria but this also
led to the right
wing
party at least so there's one in germany
called the rfd afd
uh that you know got more votes and
became stronger and people in germany
were very concerned uh about that
so this is just to to give you uh this
general
um
this general context i would say there's
another thing to be aware of and that is
uh european lawmakers had been talking
to the platforms for a couple of years
before that they have said you know you
need to act quicker on terrorism and on
hate speech and take this content off
and platforms generally have said oh
yeah sure we will do that and we look
into that and then uh not much really
happened so that was that is i guess the
historical background background i would
say
and what happened then uh so the german
lawmakers decided to enact this law what
is it actually all about
it says that uh platforms need to have a
system in place that enables users to
flag content that they deem to be
unlawful
and unlawful in this case means that is
that is it is unlawful based on the
provisions of the german criminal code
that's the german word and this that has
um paragraphs as defamation incitement
to hatred insults and survive and so and
so on so it's about i think 22 or 25
paragraphs that you could um flag
content for with regards to the this
german criminal code
and platforms would then have to
remove
reported content so content being
reported by users that is
in quotes uh manifestly unlawful and do
that within 24 hours of receiving uh
notice of it that is of course you know
putting pressure onto these platforms 24
hours depending on how you see that can
be can go by very quickly
um generally it has been considered to
be put in putting lots of pressure on
them but as you see below in in more
difficult cases they were also allowed
to take you know something like seven
days to discuss these issues and make a
decision or they could also outsource it
to an independent regulatory body so
there were ways of of getting away from
this time pressure but generally
speaking time pressure i would say was
was there and it's a main element of of
this law
in addition uh the platforms will have
to publish reports about the incoming
complaints so how many pieces of content
have been flagged according to an sdg
and then what did they do about it did
they just
decide to take it down did they do that
in the given time frame or not or did
they leave it up on the platform um they
would have to you know
publish reports about that every six
months
and the last piece uh is that platforms
that are mostly all of them i think are
from the uh from the us they also would
have to establish a legal representative
in germany that the government or other
institutions could could reach out to
and basically talk to because that was
that was not given right so these
platforms were were uh
having a tremendous impact on the on the
public sphere in germany but there was
no one that that actually the government
or anybody else could reach out and say
hey there's something happening whatever
um
because there was no office or whatever
that was actually representing them and
that changed by the nasd law in in
2018 for sure
um
the big problem uh with this law are the
fines so on the one hand you know
they being forced to react to content
very quickly in 24 hours but then also
the fines and here's the stuff on the
fines if platforms failed to implement
such a functioning system of flagging
contents
or if they're systematically failed to
take down content that is unlawful or
was deemed to be unlawful in the given
time frames or if they would not
publish the required reports then they
could get fined and that with penalties
up to several million euros i think 50
million euros so that was a steep fine
but something that is important here and
i highlighted it in in the slide is
systematically
oftentimes in the reporting uh um and
also that that happened in yeah with
scholars uh all over the place but uh
also from the u.s oftentimes it seemed
as if they are thinking if if there's
five pieces of content or whatever then
the fine would be
leveraged on these platforms that is not
the case systematically is important so
the systematic failure to um to to
comply
with these three points would actually
bring about those fines
um what is so what's the relevance of
that what's what's the important thing
about about this
net sdg
law i think what is important is it is
the first time that a western liberal
democracy so as germany
enacted this kind of a law uh with
regards to unlawful speech that actually
undermines us into my intermediary
intermediarily
liability law sorry that was that was
just too much
but um
basically uh that was given in section
230 cda was undermined by this law in
the sense that platforms are partially
held liability liable for user-generated
speech
of which they're usually protected from
by section 230. um so as you saw there
um they're not they're only held if you
will accountable if they don't you know
do these these things that i just
mentioned so they don't if they don't
have the system up if they don't react
systematically to things and if they
don't report stuff but it is a first
step at undermining uh section 230 and
that's why it's so important
especially since it happened in a
western legal democracy
and the other point and that is more my
point i think sdg is so important
because of the first point but then also
be because if you look at it and look at
it more closely you see that there are
different approaches regard with regards
to platform
regulation but also generally values uh
with regards to free speech obviously
democracy and then the digital public
sphere and i think it's important to to
look at them to be aware of them and to
discuss uh those issues also with
regards to then coming to a joint uh
stance i would say on that of how to
proceed in the future you know with uh
the us and and europe
um
here that's uh that's a post from the
human uh from human rights watch so in
their opinion this law was very
problematic right so they hear they're
saying that's the wrong way uh to deal
with uh with online abuse and it should
be reversed so criticism uh was harsh
particularly i would say uh or among
other other places from the us
um what was this criticism here i just
have a few points so there's more to
that but i don't want to bore you too
much but important is surely the first
point right
so an sdg may lead to the privatization
of your radical decisions particularly
here than regarding free speech so it's
the platforms who decide what you can
say or what you cannot say
and not a a court
who is you know which is the
democratically legitimized so that's
first big point the second point is over
blocking we're going to talk more about
it but the idea is that this law would
encourage these platforms actually to er
on the site of rather taking stuff down
instead of um
of looking
closely to it or leaving it up because
they're afraid of the fines so that is
one major piece of criticism uh
generally of course you know danger to
the free flow of information and the
internet that was mentioned a couple of
times and then also
the last point copycat laws by
authoritarian regimes it actually
happened that russia you know drafted a
law that was very similar to the sdg and
of course they are using it in very
different ways than germany does but the
the point is surely valid that that um
nation states that don't have a
democratic tradition uh like the united
states or or europe western european
countries
can use you know this uh the spoiler
play uh to to do uh things that
that are not very democrat right so
i guess that's that's fair to say
um there were a few points uh um
or arguments in favor of of an sdg or
yeah several i would say one is a very
german take uh on things uh so actually
since uh second world war
in the holocaust there's a
the german basic law the green gazettes
is actually based on the idea that
sometimes you have to restrict basic
democratic values such as freedom of
expression privacy also the market in
order actually to protect democracy
against extremists so that's a takeaway
from uh from the third right
and uh
in in in europe in general france i
think this this uh exists as well so
this belief is fundamental at least for
the german constitution
and so that's what they're saying uh you
know it's fine to have such a law
because it actually helps then to to
protect democracy that the idea behind
the other thing mentioned often in
germany is that if these platforms
operate in germany they should actually
comply with german law i guess that's
also something that people can
understand
very very well obviously their cultural
differences with regards to content
uh
i mean the easiest one is uh nazi
symbolism is not allowed in germany in
any way it's been taken down
very quickly and you get uh you get sued
if you post any of that stuff which is
not the case in the united states and
some other
countries so that is a cultural decision
i would say that is uh very important uh
to to us but this is different in other
countries other thing maybe it doesn't
always have to be these horrible
examples but also let's take nudity
facebook to down a lot of pictures of
breastfeeding women in germany or
scandinavia people just shook their
hands they nudity is not not a problem
there of that sort so they don't
understand actually but the issue is
there so those are cultural differences
that come into play with regards to
content uh um regulation and uh it's at
least something to think about should
there be should platforms react to these
cultural differences or or not or must
they eat
and then the last point is that was
received very positively was that having
this this legal entity that represents
these platforms in germany or in these
in these nations that was actually
applauded i think across the political
board people thought that would be very
important and i think
i mean
yeah i think it's an important point and
it's also obvious that the the market
power that europe has and also germany
is a reason why platforms were willing
to do that and there are many other
countries in other parts of the world
where where this is not happening just
because their their market doesn't
generate so much leverage right
um okay so that was my my my spiel if
you will on the general question of this
law and and what's what's at stake now i
want to take you a bit closer um at my
my research and and tell you what what i
have done to to analyze this course
about it
what we did is the first thing is we put
together a digital text corpora first
thing is the first corpus is based on
german i.t blocks so those are bloggers
and websites that report about tech
related issues
oftentimes tech and policy also
sometimes products we scraped that from
the web and made it accessible with the
berlin brandenburg academy of sciences
and humanities and if you want to look
at that link so there you can can access
this data
i want to just show you here a bit so
the kind of blocks we have there are our
particular it law blocks we have you
know intellectuals professors whatever
writing about these kinds of questions
uh also blogs that talk about tech
products of of different sorts and then
what i consider to be very interesting
is it news outlets so some blogs
developed actually from these kind of a
mature
individual blogs into more
professional blogs so they have real
staff they report actually every day
about developments in tech and policy
and they are
actually
the main thing that got me interested in
in the in in blogs or it looks in the
first place because they and other
bloggers may actually have a real impact
on the
the discussion that is out there in in
the public sphere and also in the more
traditional media because they're
experts and they're
they're monitored for for whatever they
post so this is the first corpus oh we
we searched for our search terms all
these terms here in german relate
obviously to this next dg law
and this was then so then so that means
we took all blog posts that mentioned
one of these search terms regarding sdg
at least once and put this this into our
our corpus our sub corpus what you can
see here is
uh the the percentage that individual
blogs uh then
um
the share that they have in the sub
corpus so how many articles that
actually they um have that that uh
mention um this particular law and yeah
you see netspolitik.org that is one of
those it news outlets that develop from
amateur to more professional and they
are very uh very involved in this
discussion about the law and other ones
as well but then also there are smaller
ones so this is basically the setup of
bloggers talking about this particular
law
what you can see here is how many
articles or how many blog posts did
these individual blogs contribute
per month to the publications about this
particular law
i don't want to get too deep into that
but what you can see is by this the
publications basically follow
the political process so as you may
remember in june 2017 the law was
enacted this around this is where you
have the first peak and then it came
fully into effect in january 2018 so
this is when most people blog about this
stuff which is not so surprising but
it's also interesting that you see a
discussion i mean then drops but it
continues basically for a whole uh 2019
so it it it still is relevant
continuously
um second corpus that we put together
and that was a little more difficult was
daily german newspapers uh we were able
to
compile text for with the for the same
search terms with regards to sdg from
those
nine most important german newspapers
they really cover i would say everything
that is of importance uh with regards to
nationwide german newspapers so very
excited to have them all together in one
place
and what you see here is again the setup
so how many articles did those
individual newspapers contribute to our
sub corpus
and the second thing here is again how
many articles did these individual
papers contribute per per month same
thing here is what you see uh they
follow the political decision making
process so june 2017 and january uh 2018
being the the two peaks uh but the the
discussion still kind of continues uh on
uh afterwards
as here you have the two graphs together
so blog posts and and uh newspaper
articles basically follow the same uh
the same pattern here um what we did
then is so i was so interested in in
this question about overblocking so we
did we took these two corpora and we
said okay now let's look how this
discussion um
evolve so this course evolves with
regards to this overblocking thesis
there were others i mentioned the
privatization of of of um theoretical
decisions or other things you could also
have you know looked at those ones but
but i was particularly interested in
that one so this is the one that i'm
picking right here overblocking again
is this idea so actually this is
interesting so german germans think that
the word is in english right or american
it's not i think he is over removal or
over regulation or just censorship but
you know germans think uh it sounds so
nicely uh english and uh if you think
it's not a bad creation maybe it's gonna
find its way back
into english language at some point but
anyway overblocking the idea is that the
fines that the netsdg law imposes or
threatens the platforms with
in the end leads them to delete more
content than necessary to avoid those
fines right simple uh um simple idea
also makes a lot of sen uh a sense and
that would then of course restrict
people's freedom of expression and would
be a bad thing
uh interesting is that there's a another
thesis out there is what i call the
anti-overblocking thesis and that is
basically the opposite of it and that
says because it is in the
platform's economic interest to keep
users there as long as possible so that
they can gather their data so that they
can sell advertisement to them and um
for these reasons they would actually
not uh you know just remove stuff you
know without you know looking closely at
it just arbitrarily
they would rather actually try to have a
nuanced deletion policy
in order not to you know
get their users annoyed and that they're
potentially leaving the con the the
platform or not contributing content
anymore and
you know that obviously being uh
this
this favor to their own business model
so this is the second thesis
and um i i would say it is uh
interesting at least to to have it in
mind and i'm gonna say this already here
um since there's no
we don't have enough data to actually
know what the platforms are doing
because the platforms are not sharing
their data there's no access to
objective data about up there about
their um
about their taking down of content i
think
we do not empirically know if the
anti-overblocking thesis or the
overblocking thesis is uh is true we can
only have theories about it but there is
no empirical way uh to decide that and
that's why i was thinking it's it's
interesting to look at them both and see
how how intensively they are represented
in a discourse or not and so that's
that's what we did
uh i won't get too technical but what we
did we took these two corpora and we
classified for some examples with a
maxqda analysis so that's a let's say
atlas it so a mixed method
working environment then we trained a
machine learning model for for with
these examples we ran this model over uh
the the corpora so the i.t blocks and
the newspapers joined together
um this throughout you know hits uh you
know
passages uh where the computer thought
this is the overblocking thesis or the
anti-overblocking thesis and then i went
through that manually and decided yeah
is that truly
uh one of these theses then i
categorized categorized it that way or
if it's not then you know it was you
know taking out of the out of the
equation
that's what we did and uh what you can
see here is a representation of that
in blue you see the overblocking thesis
and the amount of articles that mention
this thesis over time so everything that
is blue is the overblocking thesis and
you can see that's
all over
uh all over this chart it's actually
almost completely blue and the orange is
uh the mentioning of the
anti-overblocking thesis and that only
appears very few times i actually
checked the last one there in 2019 is
not really relevant so you could even
kick kick that out but it's somewhat
obvious um that the overblocking thesis
is much more prevailing here
this child does the same thing but it's
just relative to the amount of articles
published articles and blog posts per
month
so it's a relative number but it stays
basically the same so overblocking
thesis uh shows up many many times and
throughout the whole uh time frame that
we're looking at here so from the first
discussions about the nsdg law up until
it's been being in place for i don't
know what two years or something like
that
you can uh i think uh
summarize that very easily the
overblocking thesis is presented very
very often to
290 or almost 300 times while the
anti-overblocking thesis is only showing
up seven times so that is a tremendous
disbalance
and that is i would say interesting
right
uh so it's obvious that this
overblocking thesis dominates the
discourse and i think it's interesting
because of what i what i mentioned
before we in my opinion maybe it's up
for debate uh but we cannot empirically
determine which of the the two is is is
true
uh and just because we don't have access
to the platform's data
and that is why actually i was thinking
at least i would be thinking as a
researcher as an academic i would assume
that one would at least mention this
anti-overblocking thesis once in a while
to say well
it could actually also be that the
platforms will dis will do this in a
nuanced way because it's in their own
interest
so
when we started this i was actually
expecting the anti-overblocking thesis
to be much more present
at least a bit at least whatever 20 30
times or so so only seven
that is uh that is um
that was uh
very that was surprising to me as well
the other point that i mentioned down at
the the bottom is um it's also
interesting because the the sitting
german minister of justice and several
researchers in germany as well supported
that anti-thesis and particularly the
the minister of justice obviously has
has the platform to
um
to make his views uh heard so it's
interesting that that wasn't taken up
neither by the it blocks nor by uh
by the by the newspapers right and
that's just i mean i just think it's
interesting right so how how is that why
is that happening
um so these this leads me to to those
questions that i also see in the in the
realm of a critical discourse analysis
so the question is you know what's the
reason for this this balance where is it
coming from
um and who are the stakeholders or
potentially interest groups that back so
this this one thesis and why have they
been so successful actually in
communicating uh this thesis over the
other because you can say i mean yeah
and almost 90 of all articles about this
topic there was uh this this one
sentence or two that says oh you know
the there's the danger of of
overblocking happening due to an sdg so
i just think that's that's uh
interesting
uh and also with the last point so i
mentioned the minister of justice it
also seems not to have pursued the
strategy of focusing on this anti-thesis
uh very much and that's also i think a
fair question to ask what did they do
seems they they went for a different
strategy
so they they push rather different sorts
of information but is also i think
interesting again also from the academic
point uh um
if they are really if it's really at
least difficult to decide which of the
two is true then why is um
why is there hardly any mentioning of
the anti-thesis
um
yeah so that that is basically my uh
this the questions that i i'm working
with and i'm working on based on the
those results that i just showed i'm
happy to share some some insights on on
where i think this is going
uh or or what happens here but uh in the
future with regards to my research but i
also wanted to give you an update what
happened uh in the last couple of years
because right so the net sdg has been in
place since 2018 so that's four years
and the bid
um it's important i guess to say that no
fines were ever issued according to the
sdg so that just simply never happened
that's also important because i i think
it shows that
the law was rather intended to put
pressure onto these platforms but not
really to find them and gain any money
out of that
i guess of course you couldn't know that
in the beginning but looking back at it
now i think it's it's it's fair to
assume so the other thing is sure also i
mean uh yeah the in the end of the free
internet in germany did really not come
about i would say it's still possible in
germany to to freely express uh your
points of view
also because they have just not been
many reports about overblocking or or
stuff being repressed in germany at at
all right so there are a few instances
right in january of 2018 when take down
decisions where where uh whatever
didn't work out so well i would say
there were little those scandals at the
beginning but i'm really talking here
three four five instances but apart from
that never
anything else came up so i think it's
it's very fair to assume that no major
scandals uh have been there because the
the blogs and also the media that i
looked at they they would have been
really happy to jump on that and make it
a big thing and it simply happened right
and then you can see that when you read
these blog articles you can see that
nets political.org was for sometimes
trying to make a story out of this one
artist being blocked or whatever but you
just look at and say well that's that's
not really that's i mean it's always
unfortunate if any sort of speech gets
uh gets uh taken down or repressed for
the wrong reasons but those examples
don't make a case right so that was um
i think interesting
and and and is important to to mention
um
there also has been an update to an sdg
maybe i don't go into this uh right now
i can could talk about it later they
didn't change too much they made
adjustments improvements i would say but
let's not go into this but
rather let's look at the takeaways from
from this whole uh procedure or for this
whole experience i would say
what what you can take away i think
are these things on the first hand nsg
has started a very much needed necessary
debate about the power of platforms and
about the impact that they have on the
structure of the digital public sphere i
think that is
that's definitely the case uh also in in
countries other than the united states
right obviously in europe that's that's
a different thing than in in the united
states so i think
um
it it it really has helped to think
about these issues and to put them onto
uh onto a plate you could also say um i
mean there are several i think really
positive aspects i didn't list them here
but what facebook did and other
platforms is they hired people in
germany to go through content
based also with german language skills
um
in being aware of the cultural situation
in that state or in that nation also
with access to um to a better education
for their job and psychological
resources for dealing with their job as
being content moderators
because surely you know the discussion
about you know outsourcing this um this
kind of work to you know third world
countries and having those people deal
with the psychological stress that comes
with looking through all kinds of uh
content that is on platforms so there at
least in these um content moderation
places they have some you know resources
psychological support and so on so forth
i think that is definitely an
improvement
and i think also that actually
is a
an outcome of of an sdg
um
and also it's good that these platforms
are more present now in germany that a
discussion also with policy makers is
there as more lively it seems they're
reacting more to what what people care
about so those are good outcomes what i
consider to be really interesting from
the theoretical perspective are these
these next points or particularly part
uh
the point two
so there's a
u.s tradition in talking about
overblocking or you know here dafne
keller would rather say over removal or
jack balkan is talking of new speech
regulation and the idea that you know
third-party speech you know platforms
are rather willing to just take down
speech that is not their own
but belongs to two third parties
indifference to let's say newspapers
so this is a strong tradition and very
important original research
if you if you take these you know
results that i just presented today the
question really is do they still apply
and to what extent do they apply or do
they have to be readjusted or or not
or is it also a european question is it
um so
saying that um netstg may not have led
to overblocking if if one says that and
agrees on that let's just do this run
for uh for an experiment thought
experiment if you say that if you agree
on that then the question is
uh is the theory that assumed it would
lead to overblocking or to over removal
is that still valid
or not
that is i think one of the most
interesting uh questions
although again and that's what i said uh
in the last point so it's an sdg
experience an exceptional case also an
exceptional european or potentially as a
german case there's also questions so
could you say this this theory still
applies in the united states
uh or other countries but here in this
particular case in germany in europe
with this sdg law uh it just was
exceptional and there things are
somewhat different this could also be um
something or what could also be the case
is that actually
that kind of uh
theory tradition is still right we just
haven't noticed yet that actually there
was over removal um
due to
i don't think that's very realistic but
it's it you cannot um i would say it's
too early to to make an absolutely
positive claim on that so this is also
where i'm working uh what i'm working on
from a more theoretical perspective i
think that is why an sdg is so
interesting because um yeah
this this question will it lead to to
over removal is is just so pressing and
so interesting and um you know engaging
with this kind of uh thinking
um
all right so this already leads me
slowly to uh to to wrap up um with this
last point and that is the research that
i have done uh or i am engaged with uh
here at mit
and that is me trying to compare
the discourse without an sdg with the
discussion about a reform of section 2
30 as i already
mentioned
the big question
to me is so has the discourse actually
changed since the events of the storming
of the capital in 2021
so last year
so section 230 uh you know has been
discussed uh
i i would say
as the same with with the net cg mostly
uh among experts right it's not you know
people on the street are not
usually meeting in the pub and talking
sdg or section 230 uh that's that's sure
uh but um
my my case is that net cg became a thing
after it it uh
uh it was enacted and it started a
politically interested discussion also
among you know broader swats of the
population i mean not so broad but you
know a little broader and what i was
wondering is has something similar
potentially
happened after january 6 of last year
also with regards to section 230. also
the question is is it now different kind
of stakeholders different groups who who
talk about section 230 or not are they
bringing up different sort of arguments
uh when they when they talk about it uh
in the past there was um there was
always you know stuff related to free
speech in section 230 obviously but then
there was also copyright concerns and
then there was sex trafficking as a as a
big topic i i was wondering uh will
those events of the past year have
shifted this course maybe a little
closer to what is discussed with regards
to netsdg so
uh democracy as a whole extremist
behaving behavior
um and those kinds of topics that would
be that would be of interest to me also
to see then can you really compare those
two
um
discussions
well or can you not so well because
they're obviously two different kind of
laws right section 230 is much broader
and much more basic and much more in a
sense also you know important and sdg is
much more specific
um and and deals with also just a german
situation so
the question is can you compare it well
i think you can and i'll be working on
that but uh it's it's still i guess up
for debate
so what we're doing here or what i've
been doing in the last couple of months
is trying to set up a digital text
corpora in order to do actually one is
the same stuff that i told you about
with regards to the german context
now just in the us about this other kind
of law so we're putting together data
from twitter and from reddit from it
blogs that are based in the united
states or international
as well as we're looking at academic
journals and u.s newspapers in order
then again to build subcorpora that are
just about this discourse on section 230
with some you know search terms
um and then see okay
who are the people that get involved
uh with with these discussions so who
are the stakeholders what are the
arguments that they bring forward what
are the topics and so on and so forth
stuff that you can do with text data
mining
and here i think that's one of the last
slides that i have uh important maybe
for people that are interested in this
kind of a digital discourse analysis
with text data mining is the point that
it was in the past years always very
very difficult to get a grip on
current or content contemporary
newspapers
and to do text data mining on that right
so you could get access through factiva
or nexus lexus these providers though
oftentimes you know send out you know
pdf files or whatever so computing this
stuff was difficult because then you
would have to change the format into
something that's
better readable by by machines and so on
um
due to you know copyright restrictions
uh and and so on and so forth but now
something has happened something has
changed and that's at least for me the
big news
so with constellate and proquest two
actually data providers have
decided to bring to you know
to produce environments that allow you
to work on their full text data so with
consulate is it's jstor articles and
articles from portico with proquest it's
newspaper
articles and journals and other data
that you can work on in an online
environment so basically doing cloud
computing where you can work on the full
text so you can do computing on the full
text but you don't download it so you
can do that without infringing
copyrights and without these uh these
newspapers or the new york times not
being afraid that you take the data and
then post it somewhere online and then
people won't read their newspaper
anymore right so this is a this is a
very important uh tremendous step
because i can just tell you
doing the analysis in germany with these
nine newspapers what we had to do is at
the german national library they set up
a machine for me a computer that was
hooked off the the internet so it didn't
have uh um access to the internet
there they put these files for me and i
could work on them but again separated
from from the internet and only on the
premises of the national library so it
was because of these copyright and
license agreement restriction it was
very difficult and very tedious to work
with these kinds of materials and what
uh constant consulate and proquest are
providing
to us right now is is i mean for a
researcher like me uh absolutely
fascinating and and exciting
and that's also why i'm so much in touch
with with aj from the mit libraries
because i think these uh opportunities
are just uh i mean they're really truly
fascinating and and so what we're doing
in this little research team i mentioned
my so i've two europes that are working
with me and kurt on this um we are doing
these trials uh with consulate and
proquest with proquest we have been
working already for some time
so they have as i mentioned they have
the data available online they have
jupyter notebooks which allows you to to
run your python or our code and do your
analyses and then you can download
metadata or or you know graphs that that
belongs to that so we we're doing this
right now and actually today we have
gotten access to to proquest
which does the same thing just with all
these newspapers and it's i mean i'm
just i'm stoked as you would say in
california
uh is talked about the
them those you have everything there you
have uh washington post watching times
new york uh times and post and u.s today
and the wall street journal and so many
different
um resources from different political
spectra i guess um
that was never possible before so that
is that gets me very excited um and i
think is is important oh yeah so i
already talked about this so you you do
the the calculations on the cloud
computing environment and then you can
do topic modeling named entity
recognition all kinds of other uh
analysis and that is very um convenient
and very easy
it's also good for working with students
so these um
these two students i'm doing this with
they they already know uh coding but
it's also also to teach first steps so i
think these environments are great and i
also do believe and maybe that's my last
point that this kind of a setup
will boost uh text data mining research
on these contemporary resources like
these media so newspaper articles so um
i would i would if i if somebody from
mit asked me uh if they should continue
this trial with with proquest and
consulate i would say totally you should
absolutely do that i think that
researchers that are interested in this
kind of stuff will always want access of
the sort and i think that uh
universities that that have it and can
provide it to their researchers will
will will have a head start and will be
able to produce interesting research and
so i would say if you can
then you should do it and um i will see
if my home institution if if the
university of brim will be able to to do
something like this
as well
okay i think that's that was that was it
from from my side i i owe it i went a
little over time but hopefully not not
too much
um so thank you very much for for you
know listening to to my stuff i'd be
very excited if you have any any
questions for me uh also reach out uh if
you if you want to
uh with this email address or
contact me on twitter
wow thank you so much jens i'm uh i'm
completely stoked about the work as they
say in california about the work that
you're doing um i have a whole set of
questions over here but um i want to see
if i i don't see anything in the chat
right now um do we have any questions
out there
from uh maybe to start with our graduate
students
yes tomas
thank you um and it's great to meet you
and um this is extremely exciting and i
wish we would have known each other
before because i'm interested in the
same topics and
i think it's wonderful that you're
looking at platforms in a in a
transnational lens i think that's super
super interesting work that i don't see
enough of
and um i
i was really interested in in the fact
that you were looking at this case in
germany where people are you know the
idea is that it's a mechanism to
implement the law but my what i see in
the discourse around the us is that
the laws not enough right the concerns
are on for example vaccines information
there are not things that are per se
illegal to to spread with information
right but the concern
is that as if as if the law was not
enough in the case of the us
whereas i i would see in germany you're
looking at a completely different
concept so i was wondering if you if you
have thoughts about this of it this came
up in your research i feel there's like
two different imaginaries of the law
that are involved
can you can you be a little more i mean
uh specific where do you see the
difference between the united states and
germany in this case it's very vague but
i would say that i would say that in the
us the concern for example by the
government is that for example vaccine
misinformation is being spread in social
media platforms right or that hate
speech is spread on social media
platforms things that are not illegal
right they are legally permitted by the
first amendments right but um
but the concern would be that these
things are anti-social but not illegal
whereas i would say that the phenomena
you're tackling in the case of germany
is things that are that you know how do
we apply the law industry on
um
[Music]
yeah i guess say i mean
you're pointing to a very interesting
issue that is obviously the traditions
are so different right because the first
amendment is is such a i mean
knock out our argument right there's
there's nothing that you can do
about it or
or
so the traditions are so so so different
that um it doesn't make any sense i
assume also to
go at it for or potentially from the
legal perspective right because it would
be very tremendously different to set up
something that is that is really similar
right and that is already in a
so i had this question up there and
you're giving an answer to that question
you're saying basically it's so
different that in europe uh it may it
may be working in in different ways
right so there may not be overblocking
in europe because it's so different and
and unites united states it uh it may be
um different
but the thing is that one thing that i
at least
see and where i wonder
um is what happened at least with uh
president former
president donald trump is that in the
end ah he was right he was the platform
right so his speech rights were
tremendously
restricted and also it happened by
these
for-profit you know firms basically and
by no means by any sort of you know
democratic decision involved and i'm
always uh wondering if that is um
if that is a better solution
to this kind of question or not or again
the the the answer from a euro
perspective european perspective is
obvious the europeans would probably say
no
that is not a a good way to do it there
should be some democratic involvement
and there should be some some government
uh um
impact on that but also here i'm i'm not
so sure and i'm
i mean how how the u.s population or
whatever
thinks about this or how the legal setup
is
i my assumption is that this may be
different in the united states it may be
there the idea is rather that um
you know for-profit profit companies
when doing that is actually what they
feel potentially more comfortable with
right
but um i think this is exactly the point
to to think about and to continue
conversations and to to think through it
um
but also in a sense that um
i wonder what it means if these systems
are so different uh
that you know potentially as i outline
it here theory that is based on the u.s
media landscape you know and platforms
may just not apply to europe in in this
way if that is the case then i wonder if
european nations and researchers should
still you know
take take this for granted you know also
the the theory and that is something
that i that i just don't or that i'm
let's say i'm thinking about
i don't know if that's a good answer to
what you've been asking but
um no thank you so much
i wonder if if uh
one huge difference and i don't know
maybe it's not uh but
between the european context or german
context in the us context is the kind of
symbolic way that
children are used in the discourse of
censorship and censorship around speech
and the notion of protecting children
um so that for example the
in communications law here
the notion of indecent speech it which
is a violation of fcc policy is not
allowed is to protect children so you
can have a decent speech after during a
safe harbor for indecency that is late
at night when it's assumed that children
are asleep that um
sexually or excretorially
specific speech is legal right but it's
not legal you know at 6 pm when children
are soon to be part of the audience so
it's like children become a catch-all to
enable a certain kind of regulation in
the u.s and i'm wondering if they are
used in a similar um symbolic way
elsewhere
and i guess i would also well this is a
separate issue but i mean there are
certain kinds of speech that are
legally censorable in the u.s
that like defamation has certain laws
around it that speech that is censorable
in certain contexts or obscenity is is
technically you know illegal
um
a speech that
inherently does harm like yelling fire
in a crowded movie theater right so just
wondering what kinds so it's two part
question one is about the children
childhood issue and protecting childhood
innocence and the other is about the
kinds of speech that have long been
protected in the or um censorable in the
u.s and whether there's a comparable
body of sensorable speech uh in germany
outside of some of the things that
you've outlined
yeah
well i would say uh
the discourse um about an sdg did not
touch very much about protection of
children in in this regard
as as you mentioned and as it's
pervading in the united states it was
very much a discussion about
um these kinds of you know
yeah
speech rights with regards to protecting
democracy there was also so the and that
is i mean the the government actually
one one position that they pushed for is
saying that
um
we do this to protect minorities and
minority speech because they are usually
the ones whose voices are pushed to the
margins if the mainstream if you will
you know speaks up and uses hate speech
or speech that is at least you know
you know offensive or whatever then
usually those on the margins are even
pushed further out they don't speak up
they leave for uh whatever and this is
why we
we want to push this harder in order
that these uh that these communities
have have more of a opportunity to speak
up and actually in germany it is the
lgbtq
community and the jewish community has
continuously pushed for for even uh
harsher laws and also this update that
about an sdg so they have been really
trying to actually
make this this law also lead platforms
to report um unlawful speech to the
government in order that then it would
take been taken to court right away so i
guess the the it is rather been a
discussion about
these kinds of minorities and how you
can protect them
from not being
pushed out of public discourse i would
say definitely then so
children's
issues have been to my understanding
even they have been hardly been
a point in in this discussion
um that's interesting i mean it's just a
huge difference i think from the u.s
context and also just the kind of status
of of say what it means to be an
extremist
in the us and in from a legal
perspective versus
uh in germany you know when you said
specifically their argument in favor of
an sdg is that you know you restrict
democracy to protect democracy against
extremists in the u.s context i thought
you know what would be the argument in a
congressional debate about what an
extremist is and it would be uh quite
different than i i would think that in
the german context
interesting i mean that will that would
be interesting to to me um as well i
mean or to look at you know who who is
actually considered like
an extremist in both countries
um
yeah would be interesting i mean to your
second point maybe um and i and i hope i
i um got it right i would just say
interesting to me is regards to to the
to the law uh that so you have these
these paragraphs right according to the
german criminal code
um
but i wonder if
i mean if i were to interpret the move
to actually you know enact this kind of
law i would really think and guess that
it was not so much about
individual cases of these paragraphs but
rather of pushing for the attentiveness
of these platforms to cater to whatever
in this case german german needs and be
be more responsive and be more aware and
uh and these kinds of of things i mean i
um so i think what
at least in the first kind of couple of
reports these six six-month reports uh
um excitement to hatred uh was was often
mentioned in defamation and uh some sort
of insults um it turned out that uh um
the the platforms didn't take too much
down in any way right so they looked at
it but then oftentimes they made the
decision this is covered by free speech
and we just
leave it up
up there
but um
yeah again i i got the feeling that
pushing them for for more action was was
really um intended again
with this fear that you know something
could happen in this particular
situation of 2017 and being
forced to you know react
thank you
i see you have your hand up
hello thank you so much for your lovely
talk uh my question is
just to like get your general take on
the conversation of decentralization and
how that that might
be a place of research or or the sort of
move of even capital into
companies and organizations that are
considered decentralized right like
there's no one governing body is there a
potential to
challenge some of the perceptions of
platforms and
between different
continents like just general thoughts on
this is a trend it's a buzzword right
now it's used everywhere in finance and
governance so so what do you think of it
well you know i
um
i don't know if i have a good grab on
that but i would think that um
you know
trying to make money off of the
platforms as these social media
platforms do you know brings a
centralization with it you know that you
know is basically the opposite of
decentralizing them and people just you
know throwing throwing in
in stuff and that actually their their
content moderation practices and these
guidelines are actually the opposite
they are structures that try to to uh
keep
you know bring things back to the center
or at least allow them you know of to
make those decisions uh and to structure
if you will then discourse or um also i
mean it's important for them true truly
in a sense that they right they want to
create these uh these um communities
that they that they want so they can you
they can stay there but um i guess what
i'm saying is uh in difference to a
truly open platform that would allow
people to uh to contribute in ways that
they would want to and that would be
truly decentralized this kind of uh you
know closed
if you will platform this
structure you know that these kind of
platforms build up is is opposing i
guess this idea
um
i don't know if that is what you've been
asking for but yeah if you
throw that buzzword at me then that
would be
my take on it
you're muted heather
oops sorry about that um do we have any
questions from our attendees who are
outside of our main room i'm just
looking over here to see
all right well i would i will otherwise
i have a few more that i've written down
here surprise um
you you uh asked specifically you know
has the discourse changed since january
6 and i think that you
um started to answer that but i wonder
if you could answer that more and it
gets back to my question about
extremists and so on um and
um tendentially or by extension the
issue of
about uh protecting children and so on
and so far so many of the extremists
from january 6 believe that there is a
sex trafficking ring loved by democrats
and you know the democrats are the
extremists and they're the
non-extremists and so on but anyway
could you could you unpack a little bit
how the discourse has changed since
january 6 from from the u.s end at least
or is it or is january 6 how is it
understood
in a german perspective even like you
could respond from both sides
um
uh well that's a
couple of interesting things there so i
mean i would say from from our analysis
we are just not there to to make claims
about what has changed uh uh since
january 6 because we just don't have the
data yet
you know to say anything about it so i
couldn't make a clear statement on that
my assumption you know would be
uh that uh the discourse has uh has
grown uh and in the first case i mean
it's not so you know
surprising potentially but that is what
i assume and as i as i already said uh i
i assume it um drifting away from these
from these other issues to a more
politically focused and if you will then
extremist
a question but i mean it really would
have to um
we would have to to uh look at it more
closely i'm also wondering will more you
know more mainstream uh whatever outlets
or users whatever have engaged in that
conversation i assume so but also you
know there's no no data there that we
could uh
i mean i could base my claims on so i i
think well
i mean i would i would rather wait than
to make any claims that they cannot back
up in any way
um from from the german uh perspective i
mean i
i saw i mean i didn't do particularly
research on it but i mean germans have
been so critical of the last
administration in so many ways from the
right the beginning and uh it is just i
mean you get a
uh
i mean i was in uh
in the us by by the by the election uh
2000 if you're german you cannot not
think of of 1933 i mean it happened to
everyone right that you were immediately
uh you were afraid and anxious and of
course that may be not uh
you cannot compare history that easily
but uh that has been so prevailing in in
germany from from the outset
and um
uh in this in this regard also i i think
that germans have been very uh relieved
you know when there was a
takeover and an exchange of of power
that was more or less peacefully um um
and they were i mean i guess you know
shocked about what what happened there
and how um how things unfold i mean
that's very general but um this this is
how it has been it has been seen
um with regards to the platforms i think
people were um
were also uh um
interested but but also shocked i mean i
think the power of these platforms has
become
obvious to really now everyone uh what
they can do and that they can shut down
also a political leader and they also
have noticed many times that you know
things are so different now since trump
is not tweeting
every day anymore and he's not on the
news you know right and it's basically
somebody pulled the plug and things have
been completely different and i think
that has been very very much noticed uh
in in germany as well which again
doesn't necessarily make the thing uh
completely um makes it easier because it
means you have to deal with these
entities and it seems that um maybe they
maybe people are happy that the european
union is pushing in many directions you
know with privacy law so with this
national approach you have now the
digital service act and the digital
markets act um that that tries to to
deal with these platforms but on the
other hand what really matters is the
united states in in some sort of way and
there i think
people see uh or are
assuming that there is hardly a way to
really act on these platforms
potentially well that's what they've
seen you know people had to
report to congress i would have been
questioned by congress
but but there's
there's there's no uh substantial
movement that could solve or so easily
solve that that question so
these firms are very very powerful they
have a huge tremendous influence and uh
one one wonders how the us will be able
to
whatever
deal with that also from a political
perspective
one does wonder thank you uh tomas has
some questions for us i believe
no um i was wondering as the mersa
normally the specific research product
but more in your general research if you
have seen different accounts of the
digital public sphere in in the usa in
germany and and whatever that means
right
yes i mean i would i would say in in so
in so many ways right i mean uh the the
media landscape is very different you
know we we have this public uh though
which is public media broadcasting they
are financed by the state they they
inject uh something of uh
importance uh in a sense of of a certain
viewpoint or a variety of viewpoints
that i uh although i'm not so much of a
media user here as i am in germany but
but i am as well which doesn't seem to
be be present in in this way right so
that is
just right there tremendous uh
difference and um
you know that also means right it is uh
the market is is less i mean there's a
little restriction on the market side
because the the government funds uh
media in in this sort of way which
already changes the whole whole setup uh
a little more
so i mean these are very very basic uh
dimensions um but also when you look at
usership i think you know um
a lot more people in the united states
take their news from social media than
in germany it's also always rising in
germany continuously year by year but
still there's a
tremendous difference
it also uh showed
that in this particular um election that
i mentioned in 2017 actually there were
hardly any reports about um
you know bot influences or whatever this
kind of cambridge analytica stuff that
happened in 2016. i don't know if that's
the case because uh people were more
aware of that and where we're
technically already fighting these
things better or also because the media
system in germany is simply different
people relying more still more on
traditional media newspapers
this kind of public
broadcasting uh um and media
um but
i think you know it's uh it's fair to
say that the impact um uh wasn't as
uh as intense as in the united states
and and great great bitten great britain
in in 2016.
so i mean those are just a couple of um
uh of things that come to mind uh
thinking of the
uh of the public sphere but i'm pretty
sure there are many others uh uh that
come uh come to mind but may i ask you i
mean you you
maybe you're not uh um born in the
united states how is it in your country
do you recognize a clear difference
i mean yes i'm from argentina um
i
i mean the public sphere is obviously
different um
i mean very very radically different but
uh i'm thinking that like what is it
like
my question and i think you answered it
partially was
um understanding specifically of how
they see the digital public sphere right
how do they see the the realm of
conversational digital sphere and on
digital media i mean and it's something
interesting that happened very recently
it's at the government's uh
made an announcement that they were
trying to start some conversations
around
what um
good practices for some media companies
so they stop uh intoxicating our
democracy right
and i'm thinking of of of biden's
comment about uh when he was asked uh
what did he think about facebook uh and
probably related to vaccines information
he said that uh social media companies
need to stop um destroying our democracy
or something very similar i think so i
i've been thinking a lot about how
um they understand different countries
what it means to be not a
healthier democratic debate in a you
know liberal public sphere on the
internet
well i may just say two things i mean
what what brought me also to this topic
is is um the idea i mean that was a
great idea so the internet would bring
more freedom to all of us and more
democratic discourse and so on and so
forth and and then we are all aware that
maybe that's not really
going to happen so much also because
they are centralized again these
platforms and they have been agendas and
they're also as you mentioned
potentially you know spreading fake news
or polarization or polarizing content is
you know useful to them and will bring
more money in
um all of these things but i also
thought one of the issues why am i
looking at this is that
is actually technical experts who have
access to this and
not so much former polit politicians the
traditional politicians uh and it's so
difficult for i think the you know
whatever everyday joe on the street to
understand what's going to happen what's
happening here on from a legal
perspective but then also from a uh from
a technical perspective right for a lot
of you know first for
some sometimes people
didn't realize that their their feeds
right they are constructed in some sort
of way and that is based on some sort of
data and that you can be manipulated by
the the pieces of information that is
set in front of you right i mean now
people know especially of course when
you are in media studies but um for you
know years ago people weren't
necessarily aware of that so
i'm on so this research project is also
about seeing how can you translate these
technically
and legally complex issues
for a discussion in broader society so
that people can make informed decisions
about their future and the way politics
should be done
and
sdg discourse and potentially other ones
as well are just examples where i i
wonder if that actually really works or
works well yeah
and uh
what i presented here with a the
overblocking and anti-overblocking
thesis uh is just one example i would
say simply if
if this was a perfect an idea of this
course you would mention these two
options right it could be this way it
could be that way and then people would
uh you know look at researchers what
they have they said about it and then
you would make an informed decision this
is not happening for different reasons
right i haven't
gone uh into explaining that to too far
but that's interesting for me to look at
and i have at least a few ideas
there's some something that i at least
still wanted to mention because i'm
always such a european year and i am and
that's
of course uh you cannot drop that but um
i just wanted to mention that one surely
has to keep in mind that the europeans
or the european union
also has an interest in diminishing the
power of these platforms because they
have never been able to come up with
something on their own right there's no
european platform that provides i mean
except for a few i mean there's a
there's a scandinavian thing uh klanna
or so they they do finances and then
there's another one here but basically
there are no big powerful platforms that
provide people with those essential you
know social media um
uh features that whatever facebook
twitter and so on do right and so there
isn't a i think it's yeah it's obvious
that there's some political economic
incentive right to push for more privacy
legislation to push for
something like netstg also to say okay
we want to we want to have a say again
we want to get a grip on the public
sphere but also we want to uh you know
rein in potentially these platforms that
is i think both it is driven by uh by
truly
important and democratic values but it
is also there's also an economic
competition going on there it would be i
think it would be naive not to not to
see this point right
so um
i just wanted to mention that so that is
also part of the picture uh that
that you know has a
has a component in the european approach
to this
thank you thank you
thank you um thank you so much jens um i
think that uh we're gonna end here but
i'm gonna make a few plugs and
announcements before we go not just for
our grad students but for other for our
guests
um one is that a week from today we're
going to have a finnish speaker oscar
vinberg who recently defended his
dissertation on the 70s tv show all in
the family and he's really speaking from
a um
kind of political
historian's angle in a way more than a
tv studies angle and looking at the uses
of this tv show to promote legislation
for fundraising for political candidates
promoting agendas and so on and it's
just it's really interesting and quite
unique work
um the day after that a week from
tomorrow um and i'm just gonna pop this
up into the chat area i'll link here we
have thesis day when our grad students
present uh their work uh formally their
their master's thesis to the community
and mit people can come in person it's
in bartos
theater and um
other people can come in person too if
they get tim tickets which we can tell
you about you can email me or or andrew
whitaker uh so it is it is open to the
public
uh there's a reception afterwards and
it's also streamed if people want to
access that from a distance so i want to
encourage everyone to to attend that
it's really like our showcase for how
wonderful our graduate students are
and finally i'll just note i think in
many ways relevant to what we've been
talking about today on april 14 martha
minow of
harvard law school um will be speaking
with me in conversation about her uh
recent book saving the news which is you
know thinking through regulatory issues
um and how
uh
it's very dramatic title right as she's
thinking specifically about um the the
death of print media and the ways that
uh uh or prince news media and the ways
that regulations have sort of not kept
up with technological changes and i'm
certain that i haven't finished reading
the book yet but i'm certain that
section 230 is going to be a really
important issue that we're going to be
talking about so in many ways quite
different methods from you know legal
scholar from what we've been talking
about today but i think it's going to be
quite relevant to some of the issues
we've been talking about today so um
with those plugs uh for the future i
will end here and i will thank you again
jens and give you a round of applause
for presenting your work it's really
great to meet you while you are uh
visiting here with us and uh thank you
so much for sharing what you're doing so
perfect thanks so much it was a pleasure
thanks